I don't think this is just a DDOS attack
I think they got a root kid sitting
inside the servers
we stop it that's the thing it's
fundamentally invisible
yes you can't stop it almost root kits
are malware that can hide deeply in an
infected system they can also hide from
detection tools including antiviruses if
you're lucky you'll detect them or maybe
not Packers can secretly monitor you
have access to everything and you don't
even notice how to protect yourself
there are root kits for all user systems
especially a lot for Windows but you can
use these tips to complicate the
attacker's life don't open suspicious
sites or links update the system and
applications and use antivirus some
antiviruses have special anti-root kit
modules in their composition and for a
certain rootkit an individual script for
treatment could be written in general
it's possible to cure a computer but if
the malware doesn't show itself the
victim won't even try to take action be
careful and good luck